hi we're here at the Maker Faire and San
Mateo which is basically mecca for
anything do it yourself I'm inside a
muffin car which is actually a working
vehicle that just happens to have been
shaped like a muffin basically this
place is a hacker fair anything you
could hack build mod crafts or create
out of felt you can find it here how
we're all going to take a look at it in
this video I've got muffin more to say
hey I'm here in the pool with the
Western worship combat clubs actual
battleships in this pool that you can
see here they've been fighting each
other using compressed air guns that
shoot little bee bees at each other they
take damage they have pumps to pump out
water they have rotating turrets oh and
all they're not your average bathroom
toy
so this is pyro cardium it's an
interactive flame sculpture that
responds to your heart beat so we use
this the scope here is input and every
time there's no checks of pulse in
triggers the sculpture behind me to turn
on its flames so it consists of a bunch
of pieces there's the stethoscope here
obviously this has a microphone in it
that then talk to a computer the
computer run some customer the software
that Chris has developed so after the
software processing we have a USB
digital i/o board that has 24 output
channels and the computer basically
triggers sends commands the USB digital
I before telling it which animals we
want to turn on which flame effects we
want to turn on and then there's a set
of custom built I power driver boards
take those low level logic signals and
convert them to the 24 volt signals that
we need to drive the salt
it's been a great maker faire we've seen
lots of cool stuff we learned how to do
lots of cool things and now we're going
to leave you with the fire sculpture
epiphany which is about to blow up
behind me
you